[Música]
el homo habilis hasta el homo erectus
desde el homo erectus hasta el homo
sapiens dental y el homo sapiens
dentales hasta el homo sapiens sapiens
la sociología ha pasado los últimos
siglos tratando de comprender este
proceso tratando de agrupar buscar y
definir cualquier tipo de información
que encaje dentro del concepto de
evolución al fin y al cabo el humano es
el único animal capaz de modificar su
ambiente y modificar y cambiar está
dentro de la esencia humana pero hoy en
día el homo sapiens sapiens no alcanza
con ser homo sapiens sapiens hoy el
humano por excelencia es el homo exitoso
éxito
esa es la palabra del siglo 21 esa es la
palabra transversal de nuestras vidas y
al fin y al cabo es la palabra que nos
codifica que nos clasifica y que nos
mantiene todos acá tenemos a un pp a un
pequeño fetiche que en el éxito será el
mejor en algo está rodeado de las
mejores personas tener una pareja
exitosa tener padres exitosos amigos
exitosos hijos exitosos el éxito es lo
que nosotros anhelamos e incluso hacer y
no lo digo solamente yo el éxito es de
las palabras más buscadas según muestran
éxito es la palabra más buscada de
espero a marzo está en la cumbre
no es cosa menor pero no solamente la
consumimos buscándolo dentro de la
plataforma de google éxito sino con la
consumo cultural del éxito que son los
best sellers no le voy a preguntar la
canción a levantar la mano para
identificar a uno de estos pero si lo
identifican quédense lo porque el
consumo de los best seller nos enseña
cómo movernos cómo comer qué no comer
con quién juntarnos con quién dejar de
juntarnos qué tipo de persona tenemos
que ser y qué tipo de persona es más
rentable ser e incluso nos enseñan
aquellas cosas que pensé que no
necesitaba que nos podían enseñar
el éxito es transversal
todo el tiempo nos dicen todo reitero si
alguna vez ustedes lesionan uno de estos
libros hay libros de estos que nos dicen
aquí ahora comer o hasta aquí nos
conviene leer pero si el éxito en es una
palabra que ustedes les suena incapaz es
demasiado excesiva si les voy a decir
una que si les va a sonar fracaso
porque el fracaso es un poquito más
pedante
y el fracaso sí sí lo hemos palpado de
nosotros
si tiene 27 años si veis con tu hijo sos
un fracasado si tenés diez años y no
terminaste la carrera eso es un
fracasado si tenés 45 años si no tienes
una relación estable sos un fracasado si
en tu cumpleaños no te mandaron muchos
mensajes en las redes sociales o es un
fracasado no tienes amigos eso es un
fracasado y está la palabra fracaso
porque al fin y al cabo todo si no haces
en el parámetro de tiempo informa las
cuestiones del éxito por descarte eso es
un fracasado
y no solamente nos duele a nosotros en
los que estamos sacados no solamente
nosotros nos sentimos identificados con
la palabra fracaso sino los 800.000
jóvenes que mueren cada año y no mueren
porque quieren sino que se suicidan
según la campaña una muerte cada 40
segundos de los ms 800.000 jóvenes se
suicidan 800.000 jóvenes de 10 a 25 años
jóvenes como yo se suicidan y las
primeras tres causales la primera están
los problemas financieros y la falta de
oportunidades en el siglo 21 el suicidio
tiene la tasa de mortalidad más alta
inclusive que los genocidios y las
guerras suicidios
suicidio en el momento cumbre de tu vida
los jóvenes como yo eligen suicidarse y
si los 800.000 de nueve meses una
bastante abstracto porque lo ms suena
como que no existiera les cuento los 20
de los cada 100.000 habitantes que
mueren se suicidan dentro de la
provincia de chubut según la app la
administraciones políticas públicas 20
de cada 100 mil jóvenes se suicidan
entonces nos deja y nos tiene que
demostrar algo en el sentido de que
nuestros jóvenes se están suicidando yo
pensé que también era como demasiado así
que dije no esto no puede estar pasando
acá para nosotros los empeñas somos muy
exagerados o acá para los medianos van a
decir que somos no sé muy intensos pero
si pasa así que con un grupo de la
universidad hicimos unas encuestas
porque pese a que yo era la reformule
mis amigos me ayudaron a difundir las
entonces él configuró como un grupo lo
hicimos como algo grupal y en esas
encuestas pudimos ver lo siguiente
las primeras tres preguntas que les
quiero mostrar que son las más
significativas son el éxito es la
felicidad no
el depende siempre está ahí para dar una
mano pero no
el éxito no es felicidad ella te lo está
diciendo después decimos otra más en
donde dice que el 80% le gustaría
dedicarse a un hobby que no es rentable
dentro de la república y que está
haciendo las carreras que hacen los
trabajos que buscan porque tienen que
hacer algo y la tercera pregunta que sí
fue bastante significativa fue el éxito
expresión sí
así que esto nos revierte a pensar otro
tipo de conceptos porque al fin y al
cabo si nos estamos sometiendo carreras
o profesiones que son y que nos
presionan que nos atosigan y nos
determinan para meternos dentro de una
sintonía de la presión que no nos genera
felicidad
y no estamos haciendo nada y nuestros
jóvenes se nos deprimen la tendencia del
éxito de considerarme yo ante el resto
de individualizar el positivismo extremo
nos ha perdido un poco de la gracia y
nos hace dejar de pensar en lo que
realmente tiene sentido en aquellos
momentos buenas que ellos cuestiones que
realmente nos han marcado y nos han
trascendido al fin y al cabo nos someten
solamente una burbuja la demencia no
solamente dice cuestiones como éstas y
números tan aberrantes sino que también
dice algo muy importante como que el 10
de octubre es el día de la salud mental
salud mental eso recuérdenlo porque hoy
en día es sumamente importante y según
el 10 de octubre la enfermedad de siglo
21 es la soledad así que tenemos tres
cosas el siglo 21 la palabra es el éxito
y la enfermedad es la soledad y la causa
de mortalidad es el suicidio
y si eso en acción clic ahora no debería
ser un clic en algún momento porque no
puede ser que nos aislemos así somos una
generación de aislados somos una
generación donde la hipercomunicación de
las redes sociales igual nos termina
aislando y nos terminan desvirtuando la
capacidad de estar con otros nos termina
alejando
por eso para mí es importante hablar de
esto en 2015 nosotros formamos parte de
algo que fue retrasada mental para mí
éramos un equipo de raíz femenino era
vive medio se encuentra un poco carente
de la cuestión del éxito ortodoxo porque
ninguna iba a ser la más exitosa ninguna
iba a tener el mejor lomo ninguna quería
ser la más cápita la onda de esto la
onda esto para nosotras era solamente
hacerlo
y de juntar plata para comprarnos
camisetas y de meternos en cualquier
lado porque estábamos acompañadas por
que finge a cabo la que no tiene
problema con su viejo con la tenía con
su hija la cancionero con su viejo lo
tenía con su cuerpo la que no tenía un
premio con su cuerpo y con ella misma lo
tiene con su carrera porque al fin y al
cabo todos tenemos problemas pues todos
somos fracasados
y así el problema y en realidad no
siempre más la solución que cuando busca
un partido de fracaso con muchas
personas de repente se te empieza a
bajar un poco la mochila del fracaso y
sentís que no es tanto sentís que a
veces la compañía y el propósito lo
desvirtúa y no hace falta pagar con la
enorme deuda que el éxito nos ha
generado
bueno vamos a pagar nunca
así que es un tiempo atrás
me estaba tomando como unos mates con mi
amiga thalía en la playa de italia se
llama persas y tiene costillas
y charlando con thalía nos pusimos a
hablar de todas estas cuestiones de los
amores que dejamos pasar o las
enfermedades que contrae es de las
pastillas para dormir que llegamos a
tomar
de las veces que intentamos hablar con
nuestros sopas y capas no nos dan la
bola que necesitamos
de las veces que nos hemos sentido solos
y nos pusimos a pensar en todas las
cosas que nosotros seguimos haciendo sin
pensar las las cosas que hacemos de
forma de inercia inclusive y toda esta
cuestión del éxito nos lleva a pensar no
todo lo que nosotros hacemos como
sociedad lo hacemos por sumisos
o por
[Aplausos]
[Música]